you're fighting a savage you better look
savage to match the savage here we go
look at these two whoo I know me too I'm
weak damn fight to make me nervous how
about super angry yeah he does
you think cowboy flips off Winkeljohn
afree wins I don't know if he does well
if let's say hey headkick ko be a much
besides cowboy dude he'd be something
since I've known Cowboys hate Winkeljohn
might be something to it let's see what
happens here
damn he looks disciplined look at my
parry striking hands up high light on
the feet trying to not come out big
right hand
the Cowboys a slow starter so if I'm
Mike Perry's coach I great - he's off
the brake Cowboys [ __ ] good in the
clinch though damn let's see here well
that's the thing about cowboy
surprisingly good wrestling he [ __ ]
people up how dude I've seen him [ __ ]
amazing Gatling they forget because they
got picked that he does here that's
amazing he lifts his left arm and me
picks dudes all the time well he also
like he's been that doesn't nice need a
body that [ __ ] was sharp out cowboy said
he made with you all day but parries and
he was very good as well though but see
the thing about cowboy is he's like a he
seems like a fun guy right he's always
partying and driving around his jet
skiing getting wild and jump on a plane
yeah all that stuff so people think all
this guy's just wild he's also a
seriously skilled fighter oh my god a
lot of that is a little bit of a
smokescreen he's he's a absolutely an
adrenaline junkie but he's a very
skilled fighter he's a professional the
inside leg kick yeah and he has he had
some rough fights yeah
against the best in the world though
you're gonna get that this is a crazy
ass [ __ ] sport he's doing this I was
over 40 fight exactly and you're
throwing bones at each other at a high
velocity you're gonna get some knockouts
you're gonna give some you're gonna get
some it's just part of the program but
cowboy look at that good head movement
there cowboy still here dude big kiss
tell oh damn he's biting his mouthpiece
and just going forward because Cowboys
[ __ ] tall I thought Mary was a lot
shorter Perry's [ __ ] big
I think he's six feet tall Jesus tank -
man he's a tank he's a real thick dude
there when you stab his girl in this
corner mm then he lost he's like you
know I pray not anymore huh well you
know he's like his head off he can't
make 55 [ __ ] cowboy ten god it's tough
on Joey as he gets older yeah I mean
maybe Perry can make 55 maybe I'm wrong
maybe he can kill himself and get like
Rumble Johnson used to do he looks great
at 70mm that well pretty good [ __ ]
scary it's good but he's doing it on the
outside and Donald's slipping away from
it now they sparred a lot a lot before
they did a lot of sparring kind of
[ __ ] up I like when I fight Andrei
Arlovski
we sparred a bunch together so we fought
you were super tender because you knew
what the guy was good at so you wouldn't
throw your normal [ __ ] so it makes for a
more boring fight sometimes in cowboys
side though I think psychologically it
probably helps him because he's already
fought this guy before and if he did get
the better of him in training it doesn't
mean you're dealing with the same Mike
Perry I'm sure my Perry's way better now
but if they did train together and
cowboy did get the best of them then
that shit's probably on both of their
minds right now there's just no way it's
not and that's a psychological edge that
cowboy would like dude oside can travel
is nasty office i patrol he reminds me a
lot of Anthony Pettis off his back but
they're so expensive even if you know
what triangles coming there's [ __ ]
the really really stinky man well let's
see cuz I can be tough this is not some
where he wants to be let's see how he
gets out of this that was beautiful yeah
I encouraged the tape oh my god that was
beautiful that was beautiful man oh he's
gonna smash him he can go to mount
though but this is the thing that Mike
Perry was saying that he would do to him
in the gym and cowboys doing it to him
right now
see Cowboys super confident here cowboy
grappling phenomenal it's phenomenal but
not only shot that Luke chopped that arm
he's being sock him in the [ __ ] face
been torturing this guy for years right
or for well not year maybe a few weeks
copies maybe have some crucified right
so he's years I made that up but he's
doing though is exercising some serious
confidence in his my news bully this
okay he lost it though he lost the
position
he lost it he's on his back this is it
this is a Patrick cowboy snow looks
great has a great garden it seems pretty
good so far yeah no his guards hacking
and he he looks like he's trying to bait
him with the right arm
Cowboys trying to act in filthy man I
don't need the ass pipe to hit back
there everything anything goes anything
but the sons don't hit the scrotum but
you're kind of hitting super close to
snack he's like you're getting this the
taste like the house next door you
getting bombed on look at this armbar
attempt oh he spikes him and about to
break his arm he's gonna break his arm
he's passing over Cowboys breaking his
[ __ ] arm that's a wrap cowboy [ __ ]
yeah that's a wrap son [ __ ] yeah cowboy
do you know what that is for cowboy
didn't take a shot and got an armbar
didn't take a big shot we go look yeah I
like to come at me [ __ ]
I love this talking all that [ __ ] you
got appreciate it man
dude you get kicked out of your own gym
here comes this kid I don't think that's
what he's doing he's telling his life to
bring his kidneys kid man
that's what that's phenom it wasn't an
anger thing that's phenomenal
that was he wants his son oh damn man
what a cute little fella Wow
dude how happy that guy wow what a great
freaking win for Cowboys he looks so
confident dude look how confident he
looked and I think some of that is his
talent too not just that he's a really
good fighter but also that they've
they've sparked their familiar we had a
number yeah he knew he had well if it
went to the ground especially dude but
he has know my god that is even standing
up he didn't get hit with a spear
no yeah he's moving dude he looked
smooth as [ __ ] he looked superpower
standing up what a big win for cowboy
look like you got to snap his [ __ ]
arm - hey man he might have broke it we
don't even know I mean he was always mad
man very underrated